okay so I'm a little embarrassed because
I did a livestream just prior to this
one and I did just realize that you know
that the orientation of the video was 90
degrees off so if anybody is watching
here if they could give me some feedback
about you know whether I have the
correct orientation for this video so
I'm just trying to get things
straightened out here for you so you can
get something out of this this video
here so first off my name is Mario with
Mario's math tutoring and if you have
questions as we're going through this
huge SAT math review go ahead and jump
in the chat asked me a question I
certainly am welcome to that again this
is my first live stream here so I'm
still getting used to the application
here so bear with me and we'll try to
offer you some good value here as we go
through this so first of all let's just
get started and we'll talk about
parabolas as they tend to appear on the
SAT as we've been able to identify so
far by looking at some of the officially
released new SAT math exams as you can
find on the SAT College Board site so
first of all let's just go through the
three different types of parabolas and
again feel free to jump in if you have
questions or comments I'll try to answer
them as I as I go through so Elias solid
I appreciate your videos I appreciate
you for tuning in how's the how's the
audio quality and how is the orientation
of the videos it's showing up correctly
on your screen can you can you let me
know about that okay so let's get right
into this so first of all what I'm going
to do here is I'm going to oh it sounds
good okay the living word I appreciate
you chiming in on that I appreciate that
a lot okay good and how's orientation is
the video in the correct orientation
before I had done this video it was
actually 90 degrees off so hopefully
this is at the right the right
orientation now so let me know about
that if you could but let's say get
right into it so the first one I want to
show you is just y equals one x squared
okay it's good all right
thank you the living word I appreciate
that minus 2x plus one so what we're
going to do is we're going to identify
what type of form is this of the
quadratic of the parabola well you can
see it's in this ax squared plus bx plus
c form and this is oftentimes referred
to as the general form or just some
books we'll call it the standard form
but that's oftentimes confused with the
vertex form so you just call this the
general form but what we're going to do
is we're going to find the vertex and
we're gonna graph this parabola and go
from there so can anybody tell me what
the equation is for the vertex of the
parabola when it's in this form when
it's in this ax squared plus bx plus c
form does anybody know the how to find
the coordinates of the vertex well what
you want to do and what you want to
memorize is this formula right here it's
x equals negative b over 2a okay so what
you do is when you see that negative B
it just means it's the opposite of B ok
so it's negative B over 2a so what we're
going to do is this is a is 1 B is
negative 2 and C is positive 1 so
negative B is going to be the opposite
of B which is positive 2 okay divided by
2 times 1 kisses a is 1 and okay Raj
Patel thanks for jumping in ok we're
going to go through some different
questions and if you have other
questions at the end of this review of
parabolas we'll open it up to questions
so if there's things you want to talk
about we can do that as well and I just
want to mention that you know I do have
that huge SAT Math Review course if you
guys are interested there's a few free
previews that you can check out if you
know to see if it's something that's of
interest to you you can go around to my
about page on my mario's math tutoring
YouTube channel so check that out if
that's something that you think would be
useful but continuing on with this you
can see 2 divided by 2 equals 1 so the
x-coordinate of the vertex is going to
be 1 comma something right so how do we
find that y-coordinate of the vertex
Raj Patel is asking us how much time
we're gonna be online for I think maybe
around I don't know maybe 20 minutes
half hour or something like that this is
my first live stream so I'm gonna try to
keep it relatively short but we'll just
we'll just see how long it goes and just
kind of take it from there
so then what you want to do is you want
to take that that one and we want to
find the y-coordinate so how do you find
the y-coordinate the vertex after you
found the x-coordinate well what you
want to do is you want to go ahead and
put it back in for 4x here okay so if we
put 1 in for X we get let's just do it
down here so we so people can follow
along so it's going to be 1 times 1
squared minus 2 times 1 plus 1 well 1
squared is 1 times 1 is 1 okay minus 2
times 1 which is 2 plus 1 more okay and
you can see 1 minus 2 is negative 1 plus
1 is 0 right so basically what we have
here is we have our vertex is 1 comma 0
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to graph that parabola so I'm just
going to draw this freehand I don't have
some graph paper in front of me at the
moment but we're going to locate the
vertex which is right 1 up 0 ok
and then what you want to do is you want
to draw on that line of symmetry okay
it's a vertical line of symmetry that's
what divides a parabola in half right so
if you take the mirror image over this
line you know you're gonna find some
corresponding points okay so what we're
gonna do now is we're going to plot some
additional points and so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to pick an easy point
and what you can do is you can just make
a table like this and the easy point to
allocate is the y-intercept all you have
to do is set X equal to 0 and that'll
give us the y-intercept so I'm going to
go back over here I'm going to put 0 in
for X and if you do that you can see
that this is going to make this 0 it's
going to make this term 0 we're gonna
end up with just with positive 1 so you
can see that our y-intercept is going to
be at 0 comma 1 so I'm just going to go
up 1 and there's a point and then if I
reflect it over that line of symmetry
there's a corresponding point so now
we've got three points we can get a
pretty good idea what our graphs gonna
look like right ok it's opening up and
you can see that we have a minimum value
or the lowest value here at y equals
zero okay so this is the general form of
a parabola definitely something you want
to know and understand for the SAT but
now what we're going to do is we're
going to go over to the other forms of
the parabola but before we do that
does anybody want to jump in and ask a
question about you know how this general
form of the equation of a parabola works
go ahead and feel free if there's
anything you want to ask me see
basically this a value tells you whether
it's you know if it's positive it means
it's going to be opening up okay like
this if it's negative it's going to be
opening down like this right and the
larger this a value is like if a was
three for example what that would do is
it would stretch the graph making it
narrower and if it was small or like say
like 1/2 or 1/4 or something like that
it would make the parabola wider okay so
it's compressing it so so that's the
basic idea so when you see these
parabolas you know that's a parabola
because the highest degree is two it's
at x squared type graph okay so that's
the idea so I think what we'll do now is
let's go on to some of the other forms
of the parabola let's go on to the
vertex form now so the vertex form is
going to look something like this it's y
equals a times X minus H squared plus K
ok and the vertex is going to be at H
comma K right and again this a value is
just like the a value in the last
problem that we were working with it's
what stretches the graph or compresses
the graph or if it's negative it
reflects the graph over the x axis so a
simple example would be something like
this say we wanted to graph y equals
negative 2 times X plus 1 squared minus
4 ok so can anybody tell me the
coordinates of the vertex ok so what do
you think so where is the vertex of this
parabola well if you take a look you can
see this H value here that's the x
coordinate the K value here's the y
coordinate and the thing to remember is
that the number that's grouped with the
X okay somebody just jumped in Raj Patel
says negative 2 Obata camus of a I
apologize if I'm mispronouncing says
negative 1 negative 4 yeah you're
absolutely right it's negative 1
negative 4 and the thing to realize is
that the one that's grouped with the the
X has the opposite
so it looks like it's plus-one here but
it's actually the opposite sign it's
going to be negative one and the
y-coordinate is going to be negative
four okay so the y-coordinate has the
same sign okay and the one that's group
iudex has the opposite sign okay so what
we're going to do now is we're going to
go ahead and graph this parabola and
graph the vertex negative 1 negative 4
so I'm going left 1 down 4 I'm going to
sketch in that axis of symmetry like so
alright and then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pick some some easy values
and some easy values what we can do is
we can focus in on this a value and
graph y equals negative 2x squared okay
this is called the parent function it's
basically what gives you the the general
shape of the graph whether its opening
up or its opening down and how narrow it
is or how wide it is so what we can do
is we can make a table an XY table like
this and we'll just pick some easy
values like maybe 1 & 2 so if I put 1 in
for X I get 1 squared is 1 times
negative 2 is negative 2 and then 2
squared is 4 times negative 2 is
negative 8 but now here's where students
go a little bit off instead of graphing
from the origin I'm going to graph from
this vertex point right here so I'm
going to go right 1 and down 2
okay and then I can take the mirror
image over the line of symmetry like
that and then I can also go right to and
down 8 I'm just going to estimate this
one because it's going a little bit off
our graph and then if I take the mirror
image over that line of symmetry I get a
corresponding point so it gives us a
pretty good sketch a pretty good idea of
what the parabola looks like right there
okay so you can see this graph has a
maximum value at the vertex and that's
going to be at negative 4 and it just
continues to go down from there so
that's going to be the maximum the
highest that the parabola reaches so
what do you think any questions at this
point about the vertex form of a
parabola this is the form that you want
to familiarize yourself with and just
get used to recognizing that the x
coordinates the opposite sign and the y
coordinate as the same sign as that H&K
here above so any questions about that
anything you want me to talk more about
in regards to the quadratics therefore
the vertex form
okay so if you're just joining joining
us here feel free to jump in with any
questions you might have we can talk
more about parabolas here I'm going to
do one more example talking about the
intercept form now of parabolas and then
we can open it up to questions that you
have just regarding that SAT Math
section okay Obata is asking how do we
convert from standard form to vertex
form okay that's a great question okay
so let's go back to this problem that we
were doing here just a minute ago see
this is in the standard form right here
okay and what we're gonna do is we're
going to convert it to the vertex form
that's what you're interested in right
so let's go ahead and make some room
down here so what you would do is you
would say y equals x squared minus 2x
plus 1 okay and there's two different
ways to do this um one way to do it is
called completing the square and what
you do is and there's different ways to
do this as well but what I'm going to do
is I'm going to move this one just a
little bit over to the side just to kind
of get it out of the way so I'll show
you that so y equals x squared minus 2x
plus 1 and then what you do is you take
half of this coefficient in front of the
X term so half of negative 2 is negative
1 and if you square it that's going to
be positive 1 but you can see out of
thin air I'm adding 1 to the right side
of this equation I don't want to change
anything or change the value of the
right side so I'm going to
counterbalance that by subtracting 1 ok
so then what we're going to do is we're
going to factor this quantity right here
which works out to be a perfect square X
minus 1 squared and over here the 1 and
negative 1 actually cancel each other
out that's just 0 but I'll just write in
plus 0 so now you can see that this is
in the vertex form and you know our
vertex is going to be over here at
positive 1 comma 0 and you can see
that's where the vertex was when we
graphed it the first time right here 1 0
okay so that was an excellent question
so converting from the general form to
the vertex form you can just use it
completing the square technique the
other thing that you can do is you can
use the vertex over here c1 0 and if you
know that vertex form okay which we just
talked about which is the y equals a X
minus H squared plus K you can put the 1
in for
each okay okay head Raj says I
understand it now while it was so simple
I was stressing myself out okay well
okay don't get stressed out we're trying
to clear things up here in this video
but and then the K value is going to be
plus zero and the thing to realize is
that this e value is going to be the
same a value as we have up here see how
a is the number in front of the x
squared term that's one that's going to
be the same a value right here so this
is also one so you can see you can
either just go ahead and substitute in
that vertex the h and the K or you can
do that completing the square method
that I showed you down here so those are
some great questions definitely you guys
are asking some good ones so any other
questions that you want to ask regarding
what would cover so far about parabolas
and graphing parabolas and finding the
vertex and the different forms we still
have one more form to go and that's the
intercept form okay Obata says thanks oh
you're welcome
I'm glad that helps let's talk about
let's talk about the intercept form now
so we're gonna cruise on over to another
example and we can always come back if
you have more questions about that but
this third form that we're gonna be
talking about is the intercept form and
it can be written in this form like this
y equals a times X minus M times X minus
n okay and what you can see is this is
basically like a factored format okay
it's like in a factored form and so what
you do is I'll give you an example like
say for example they gave us a problem
like y equals 3 times X minus 4 times X
minus 2 well what you can do is you can
set these factors these groups equal to
0 right and if you do that what do you
get you get x equals 4 and you get x
equals 2 and so what you would do from
there is you would go ahead and plot
those X intercepts okay that's going to
be at positive 2 and positive 4 and then
what you want to do is you want to draw
on that line is symmetry the line of
symmetry is going to be halfway in
between those two x-intercepts so if
you're not sure what it is you can add
them together and divide by 2 so 6
divided by 6 divided by 2 equals 3 and
this is the line x equals 3 ok so that
divides the parabola
okay so from there what you can do now
you know the x-coordinate the vertex
it's going to be right along that line
of symmetry you just have to take that x
equals three value put it back in for X
here and you can solve for the
y-coordinate of the vertex
so if we do that 3 minus 4 is negative 1
3 minus 2 is 1 and 4 multiplied by 3 we
get 3 times negative 1 times 1 is
negative 3 so that's going to be our y
coordinate of our vertex ok so are you
with me so far any questions about how
we found that vertex so that's the key
so you found the found the vertex you've
got the two x intercept points and with
those three points you can get a pretty
good sketch of the graph now again if
you look at this a value if the a values
positive remember the graph opens up if
the a value is negative that means the
graph is opening down right and then
what the 3 does you know the larger this
a value is the more that it's gonna
stretch the graph and what that does it
makes it narrower the smaller that it is
it's like 1/2 or 1/4 it's gonna make it
wider okay like that all right so again
this graph has a minimum value because
that's a how low it goes okay but it
doesn't have a maximum value it keeps
going up to positive infinity so so far
we've basically gone through the three
different forms that you would likely
see the equation of a parabola on SAT or
a quadratic however you want to say it
either the intercept form or the vertex
form or that general form so if anybody
has any questions about what we just did
so far ok let's see so my MN I'm sorry
if I pronounced your name right says how
do you factor when the a value is
greater than one okay so how do you
factor in the e value than one okay
that's a great question well what you
can do is okay let's see if we can look
at an example here say for example you
had let's just say it was let's say 3x
squared I'll try to make up a good one
here for you so say it was like let's
say something like this and which we
make this value so mmm let's just say
that this was let's see how about 13
like that okay so okay so how would you
factor something like this well that's
like that's a good question actually let
me let me pick it a slightly different
example here let's just say it was like
two x squared and let's maybe make this
minus fifteen and let's maybe say this
is let's say plus 7x okay is that a good
example there so you can see that a
value is something other than one and
you're wondering how to factor it right
okay well there's there's a couple
different methods some students they
like to do the guess and check method
but I find that for a lot of students
you know that can be a little bit
challenging especially when the numbers
are larger so what you can do is you can
take this two and you can multiply it by
the negative fifteen and what you do is
you have to ask yourself what two
numbers multiply to negative thirty but
they have to add to the middle
coefficient which is positive seven so
can anybody tell me what two numbers
multiply to negative thirty but add to
positive seven what would that be mmm
it's like a riddle this is the toughest
part about the problem but basically we
can figure out this you've got it so
basically you can see 10 times negative
3 is negative 30 but 10 plus negative 3
equals 7 and so then what you would do
is you would split this middle term into
10x and negative 3x okay and then bring
down the first and the last term like so
all right and then all you have to do
now is factor by grouping because you've
got four terms so you're going to group
the first two and you're going to group
the last two and these are actually
added together okay these two groups and
parentheses and then what you do is you
factor out the greatest common factor so
I'm going to factor out a 2x which
leaves us with X plus five and I'm going
to factor out a negative three which
leaves us with X plus five and you can
see now you've got this X plus five in
common if you factor that out out of you
know this group and this group you're
going to have X plus five times 2x minus
three and now you've got it factored and
again the nice thing about factoring is
if you foil all these together you know
multiply these together so Rodge does
this is a factorization is easy when you
when you teach sir okay well I
appreciate that you guys can just call
me Mario you don't have to
nice or anything like that I just want
to give you some information so that
help you
you know score better when you take the
SAT and help you in their math class so
so I definitely I'm glad you guys are
getting something out of this so I think
what we're gonna do we're at the 20
minute mark right now I think what we're
gonna do is we're gonna have to wrap up
this live stream this is my first
experience with live streaming so I hope
this was helpful and if you have more
questions you know just definitely check
out my youtube channel Mario's math
tutoring and if you're getting ready to
take the SAT definitely check out my
huge SAT math review video course I also
have one for the AC T it's the huge AC
t-- math review video course and you can
find those on my about page on my
Martin's math tutor youtube channel or
on my website Myers math tutoring com or
you can see it on the header the channel
header at the top of the Tube channel so
so that's basically what I would
recommend for right now if you're
interested check that out otherwise stay
tuned for more live streams I'll
probably try to do these at some type of
regular interval I'm not sure yet how
I'm going to set that up but I think
what we're going to do is just kind of
wrap things up for today definitely
check out those videos on my youtube
channel I have a number of videos
regarding the SAT as well as the a CT
and then things covering the topics that
we cover today such as completing the
square factoring graphing parabolas so
if you want to review those concepts
more you know definitely go ahead and
over there and check those out when you
when you'd like to do that so alright
enjoy the rest of your day thanks for
tuning in and I look forward to helping
you in the future and we'll talk to you
soon